So let's take a look and see how our
Jersey Square team is doing in tinkering out
their revenue streams, that is how much
money each segment is willing to pay
and how would they like to pay this amount.
So what they discovered as we found out earlier
is that they have two customer segments
Sport Jersey Owners and Single Game Attendees
and as you will think that the Single Game Attendees
would actually like to pay per rental, that is
you are going to rent a jersey for one-time use
from Jersey Square but the people who already own
Sport Jerseys kind of like the idea of an annual
subscription and now getting out of the building
they actually talk to enough customers
and have enough data to realize that these
Sports Jersey owners would pay $200 a year
to get a clean, pressed, dry-clean jersey
for each game. It isn't clear yet
in their customer discovery process,
how much the Single Game Attendees will
pay but they intend to talk to more
customers and fill in that data.